hey you guys it's max max tech Samsung
just released a new Galaxy Tab s6 and
today we're gonna be comparing it
against the s5 yi and figuring out is it
worth spending the extra money for the
tab s6 or should you save some and go
with the s5 II that we did multiple
videos on a few months ago when it
launched and we were really impressed by
now they're both sitting here on the
table in front of me and you probably
cannot tell the difference between them
that is because a lot of the design is
very similar the screen resolution is
the same we're gonna test our brightness
here in just a second but there actually
are some minor differences the s5 II is
slightly lighter and also slightly
thinner but when you look at up even
when you feel them and hold them in your
hands you cannot tell the difference and
the fact that both of these are so
lightweight makes them really nice to
use for extended periods now when I go
ahead and flip these over now you'll
start seeing some of the differences
with s5 e we have a single camera and I
will be taking a photo shortly compared
to the dual camera system but the even
bigger difference is this little bevel
with little kind of a spot for the S Pen
that is included with the tab s6 and
that will connect magnetically on the
left-hand side we have these little
connectors for the keyboards along with
a couple cutouts that help the tablets
hold more securely to the keyboard and
at the top we see we have microphones
here and also on the bottom so both
these tablets have quad speakers which
is really nice for different content
they both have a USB c4 connections with
15-watt chargers same amount of battery
but when we flip to this side we start
noticing a little bit of a difference we
have the volume rockers here both of
them have micro SD card slots I'll talk
about the capacities and just a second
but as you can tell with the s5 II the
power button is different that's because
it actually has a built-in fingerprint
scanner that I really liked it's super
fast with a tab s6 we have an optical
underneath the display fingerprint
scanner which is interesting because
Samsung smartphones use ultrasonic
underneath the display sensors and this
one actually is quite a bit faster and
more reliable so every single time I
turn it on it is quite
and it gets it so that is a positive but
you do have to turn on the display first
whereas with a tab s5e the scanners on
the side and it's both the power button
so you can just in one little click both
turn on the display and get into it so
it is faster having that and I would say
I would prefer that Spivey's a
fingerprint scanner the last thing that
I want to mention design-wise the width
the tab s6 we have a little bevel all
around the actual tablet which makes it
just look a little more premium has a
little bit of a shine to it when light
hits it compared to just the standard
s5e both these tablets have excellent
OLED displays they have high resolutions
large pixel densities and really deep
blacks because of the fact that their
OLED and on paper they're basically the
same well it's very interesting is
looking at them now when I max out the
brightness the s5e looks slightly
brighter but it also has a cooler white
balance out of the factory compared to
the tab s6 and I don't know if that's
just manufacturing differences or how
they're tuning them but that is
something to note now as far as
reflectivity and viewing angles if
you're looking from the side all of that
looks to be exactly the same jumping
into a YouTube video I'm gonna play back
this 4k HDR file of course we can't
stream in 4k well we can't do 1440p
which gives us a lot of detail here one
big difference though is that with a tab
s5e the YouTube app is not playing HDR
playing standard whereas with the tab s6
it is playing HDR and all the software
is up to date now depending on the shot
you could prefer one or the other but in
general you're gonna get greater dynamic
range and more highlight details with
HDR on now some other apps could support
HDR with the s5e but the s6 is HDR 10
plus certified so if that's what you're
looking for you're gonna get a better
result with the s6 but either way both
these have a fantastic experience if you
want to watch movies music videos
anything like that now there is one
other major difference between the
displeased and that is support for an S
Pen
the s5e does not support it not even if
you buy one after market it just is not
set up for this whereas the tab s6 does
support it and the s-pen is included in
the box so if you're somebody that likes
to draw you like to take notes do things
like that you want to have a stylus you
definitely have to go for the tab s6 and
with the tab s6 we also like as I
mentioned have this little cutout or
this little embossed area where the
s-pen now magnetically connects let's do
it the right way
there you go and that just makes it
easier for you to keep it with you it
actually stays on fairly well it does
wiggle around if you bump it but I think
this is a much better solution than what
they did with the tab s4 now along with
the updated s-pen and the little area
that's magnetic we have a new updated
keyboard that has a couple new things so
first off let me set this down here we
actually have a nice little slot for the
s-pen here and let's go ahead and attach
this there we go
so this helps out to be able to not lose
your s-pen if you're gonna be throwing
it in your bag and this little side
literally just pops off like that you
can pull it out flip it just like that
so that's actually really nice and I
love that it's actually a two-piece
system now instead of a one-piece
keyboard so you can detach the keyboard
part of it and just have this little
kind of protection for the back and your
little holder for the s-pen or you can
actually let's get this attached
magnetically and then now we have a full
cover so it's very flexible and there's
also a little kickstand built in here
and so we can actually adjust the angle
so this is all the way down right here
let me turn this back on so it gets
fairly low or I can raise it up if I'm
going to be sitting down and as you guys
can see there's also one other update
with the keyboard and this is very
exciting and this is the trackpad so
right away when we put our keyboard on I
can already just touch it and have a
cursor just like on a laptop and this is
really gonna help make this a better
laptop replacement we actually are
have an upcoming video comparing the
iPad to the Galaxy Tab s 6 as far as
which one's a better laptop replacement
so make sure you guys are subscribed you
guys have notifications enabled the tab
s5e does also have a keyboard accessory
it is less expensive than the one for
the tab s6 but it's much less capable we
don't have that track that on there and
we don't have that little cool kickstand
either
so it's a more traditional kind of
tablet keyboard typing experience is
pretty good for something that's so
compact but if I was somebody that
wanted to use a keyboard quite often
often enough to spend over $100 on one I
would definitely try to go for the tab
s6 because of the extra capabilities now
it's time to compare the speakers
now as I mentioned earlier both these
have quad speakers which is great but is
the sound quality the same or is a tab
s6 better let's start out with the s5 II
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know about you guys but to us
the tab s NYX does sound a little bit
louder maybe a little bit more full you
guys let us know down in the comments
section below
before we talk about performance which
is a major difference between these two
let's take a quick look at cameras so
the Galaxy Tab s5e does have a front
facing camera a camera on the back but
the s6 actually has dual cameras on the
back which might be a first at least
that I know of for a tablet I'm not
really sure why you need an ultra-wide
lens but here's a shot with the regular
one there we go and then we have an
ultra-wide which is crazy and you guys
let us know which one looks better if
you can tell a difference and now it's
time to talk about performance where we
should see a pretty substantial
difference
so both these have Snapdragon processors
we have the 674 the s5 II and then 855
which is more of a flagship processor
for the tab s6
they're both eight cores but the tab s5e
has six slow chorus and too fast pours
whereas this one has one ultra-fast core
three fast chorus and then four
power-saving cores I'm gonna start
running Geekbench v here we're going to
compare the results but I also wanted to
talk about the RAM differences in the
storage differences if we compare the
base models the tab s6 comes with 6 gigs
ram compared to 4 with s5e and then if
you spend $80 more you'll get double the
storage for both from 64 to 128 and from
128 to 256 and on top of that you get
two extra gigs of ram so you can get up
to eight with the tab s6 compared to six
that's not a huge difference but it is
there now another thing I want to
mention while we're waiting for this
test to finish up is the battery life
both of them have the same battery a
little over seven thousand milliamp
hours but because of the weaker
processor in the s5e
you will get better battery life alright
finally the s5 II is finished that took
a while and in multi-core we have a
score of almost double with the tab s6
but in single core it's actually more
than twice as fast and that is we notice
in those little things like opening up
the web browser or
certain apps don't need all of the cores
it definitely feels a snappier and if
you're gonna do intensive CPU tasks
different larger apps photo editing some
video stuff you definitely want the
better performance of the tab s6 and as
far as graphics as you guys can see the
difference is massive a close to four
times faster and four times more
powerful with the tab s6 and this is
something that you actually notice
day-to-day with the s5 II in my review I
complained about stutters and little
glitches and slowdowns when you know
swiping through the UI and with the tab
of six it is much better improved now
along with that it for somebody who's
gonna be doing things like gaming you
will definitely notice a difference now
let me know down in the comment section
below if you want angelica to do a
gaming comparison between these two i
think we know the results but if you
guys want to see a video like that with
a couple different games let me know
down below alright guys so there you
guys have it the comparison between the
s5 II and the tab s6 and the last thing
that we need to talk about is the value
is it worth spending more money on the
tab s6 and I would say absolutely if
you're watching this video and you're
seriously contemplating between buying
one of these over the other I would say
definitely spend the extra money if you
need some time you need a wait save up a
little more please do that and get the
tab s6 now with that said there is still
a market for the galaxy s5 II if you're
somebody that just needs a web browser
you're gonna watch videos listen some
music simple tasks like that this will
still get the job done as long as you
know that you're not going to be running
a bunch of apps multitasking using decks
stuff like that this could still be a
great device but make sure you know what
you're getting into and I would say if
you're doing that don't spend the extra
money to get extra storage your RAM
unless you're buying it refurbished
which you can actually get some pretty
good deals I will leave a link down in
the video description and you could
still be happy with this but for most
people I would say spend extra money get
the type of six especially if you want
to get a keyboard as well because that
keyboard is so much more capable you can
detach it you have that
stands and of course you get the S Pen
with it included a lot more performance
so thank you guys for watching if you
guys want to see more videos on these
make sure you guys click that little
circle to subscribe and enable
notifications down below we actually
already did a comparison a width iPad
pro against the top s6 and some of the
results were very interesting so if you
guys want to see that click that little
box right over there and we will be
doing a full review as well that you
guys do not want to miss out on this one
max was max tech and I will see you guys
in the next video
[Music]